Speaker 1: So many things happening from the
standpoint of vaccine requirements and mandates,
the big news yesterday is that New York City
will be mandating vaccines.
If you want to go to restaurants, if you want
to go to gyms, and if you want to go to most
indoor entertainment type venues.
New York City Mayor Bill de Blasio mandating
covid vaccines for certain indoor activities.
The order goes into effect August 16th with
full enforcement starting September 13th.
De Blasio says the mandate, known as the key
to NYC pass, would encourage increased immunizations
to combat the spread of the Delta coronavirus
variant.
The mayor's order comes a day after de Blasio
mandated vaccinations for all of the city's
new hires.
De Blasio added the city will begin inspecting
businesses for compliance in mid-September.
All affected customers and workers can either
provide their vaccination cards or upload
proof of vaccination to the Excelsior Pass
application.
New York City is thought to be the first in
the nation to implement such a mandate.
Joe Biden responded affirmatively when asked
at a press conference yesterday if he believed
other cities should follow suit.
But stakeholders across the food industry
raised concerns about how the program will
work.
They are overwhelmingly concerned about their
saying, listen, this is not like checking
an ID to make sure someone's really 21 before
you serve them alcohol.
This is much more invasive.
It's going to really affect restaurants.
But needless to say, de Blasio is going forward
with it.
I believe it will encourage more people to
get vaccinated.
Here is Bill de Blasio talking about this
yesterday during a press conference.
Speaker 2: This is crucial because we know
this will encourage more vaccination.
We've seen it already.
We've seen the impact of the mandate we've
put in place for city workers already starting
to move people to vaccination.
We've obviously seen the positive impact of
incentive as well.
The goal here is to convince everyone that
this is the time of stop the Delta and the
time is now.
And that means getting vaccinated right now.
This new policy will be phased in over the
coming weeks.
So we've been working with the business community,
getting input.
We're going to do more over the next few weeks.
The final details of the policy will be announced
and implemented in the week of August 16th.
Speaker 1: OK, so without question, this is
happening.
The question the questions are how is it going
to be implemented and how is it going to be
enforced?
New York Times also writing New York City
will require workers and customers to show
proof of at least one dose for indoor dining
and other activities.
We are seeing other examples of this as well.
A growing number of Los Angeles restaurants
and bars are themselves requiring proof of
covid-19 vaccination.
Microsoft will require proof of vaccination
to enter their buildings in the United States.
The full opening of its offices will be no
earlier than October 4th.
So they've got a couple of months.
Tyson Foods will be mandating vaccines for
its U.S. workforce.
We know that food processing plants were big
points of spread relatively early in the pandemic.
So this is happening.
The questions are how will the enforcement
work?
And I know a lot of you have been emailing
me saying, David, you know, it's really easy
to forge vaccine cards.
It's not only easy, theoretically, it's already
happening.
We already are aware of all sorts of stories
of people having and presenting fake vaccine
cards.
So there's no doubt that it will happen to
some degree.
But the point here is, you know, you put a
welfare social insurance system in place.
There will be some people who misuse it.
But does it do good at the macro level?
You put something like this in place.
Will some people lie about being vaccinated
and get away with it?
Yes, but they're already not vaccinated.
If you incentivize a bunch of people to go
and do it, we are slowing the spread and hopefully
getting beyond the pandemic.
So it's happening.
We will see how it all rolls out.
And there is no doubt that you will continue
to see protests and more.
There are some who are calling this Nazi like
and we will get to that a little bit later,